今回のセクションでは親コンポーネントと子コンポーネントの間で
データを受け渡す方法について見ていきたいと思います
そういうのができたら便利そうですよね
BGSはそのやり方を用意してくれていまして
まずは親コンポーネントから子コンポーネントに
データを渡す方法について見ていきたいと思います
なのでちょっとコンポーネントを一つ作りますね
カウントを表示するコンポーネントということで
showcount.viewとします
で、テンプレートを用意して
その中に何でもいいんですけれども
countコロンとしておきます
で、これを親コンポーネントとつなげたいので
app.viewの方でスクリプトセットアップとして
で、importでshowcount.viewとした上で
テンプレートでこちらのshowcountをタグとして書きたいと思います
そうするとですね、こんな風にcountコロンと
コンポーネントが表示されているのがわかると思います
さあ、その上でこのココンポーネントの
カウントの右側のところに
親コンポーネントで定義したデータ
もうちょっと今レフとして0としますね
これを表示させたいとします
つまり親から子にデータを渡したいとします
この時にどうするのかと言いますと
なんと適当な属性を
このココンポーネントのタグのところにつけるんですね
で、値にその渡したいデータを入れます
で、このままだったら普通の属性のように扱われてしまいますので
このwhoという属性は
特別な親から子にデータを渡すために使っているんだ
ということを明示的に示す必要もあります
それはどうするのかというと
ココンポーネント側のスクリプトの中で
実はdefine propsという
これは関数になっていまして
インポートをしなくてもいきなりこんな風に
コンポーネント内で使えるものなんですけれども
これを呼び出す必要があります
で、引数に配列を入れることができまして
そこに文字列で
このデータを渡すために使う属性の名前を入れます
こうすることで
このshowcount.viewのコンポーネントは
whoという属性を親コンポーネントで指定された時だけは
そのwhoという属性は普通の属性ではなくて
データを渡すために使っているものなんだと
応用意識をするようになります
ちなみに名前の話なんですけれども
そういうデータを渡すために用いる特別な属性のことを
propsと言ったりします
だからこっちの関数の名前は
define props
propsを定義するという関数名になっていたりします
で、実はもうこの段階で
このwhoというデータを
テンプレートで使うことができまして
このままいきなりwhoと書くだけで
なんとこんな風に
0と親のデータを表示できているのが
わかると思います
もしこのwhoをスクリプト内で使いたい場合は
実はwhoとしてもアクセスできないんですけれども
このdefine propsが
返り値で
Reactive Objectを返してくれていまして
その中に親から渡された全てのpropsのデータを
プロパティとして持ってくれていたりするんですね
なのでprops.whoとか書くと
ちゃんとですねスクリプトで使えるようになります
のでこんな風に0と出ているのがわかると思います
なのでスクリプトでpropsのデータを使いたい場合は
こんな風にrefine propsの返り値を使うようにしてください
これが親コンポーネントから
コンポーネントにデータを渡す方法になります
まずコンポーネントでdefine propsを使って
データの受け口を作って
親コンポーネント側でpropsとして
属性でデータを渡すわけですね
ちなみにcountはref objectですので
もし例えばですけれども
ボタンを用意した上で
atclickイコールでcount++として
reactiveなデータをカウントアップさせた場合は
ちゃんと再レンダリングされるんですけれども
その時はこのpropsを渡した
コンポーネント側の画面も
今回のようにpropsの値が変わる時は
ちゃんと再レンダリングされますので
こんな風に数字がカウントアップされているのがわかると思います
なので常に最新の親のデータが
コンポーネント側で反映されるというわけですね
またこのpropsもreactive objectになっていますので
ちょっとコンソールで見ると
こんな風にproxy objectと出ると思うんですけれども
これもですね
親のデータが更新されたら
ちゃんとそのオブジェクトのプロパティも更新されます
ので例えばですけれども
watch effectの中とかでprops.fuとか使った場合は
ちゃんとその変更も
propsがreactive objectになっているので検知してくれます
だから普通のreactiveなデータと同じように
使うことができるわけですね
その上でここちょっと重要なんですけれども
propsはread onlyになっていまして
コンポーネント側から
こんな風に変更することはできません
一切はいとかに書き換わらないんですね
こんな風にコンソールでもread only
読むだけですよと
こういう警告が出ます
なのでpropsはあくまでも
読み取り専用
親コンポーネントからのデータを
ひたすらただ受け取るだけなんだと
思っておいてください
あくまでもpropsのデータの流れは
一方通行なんですね
親コンポーネントから
コンポーネントに対してのみ行われます
だからデータを変更させたい場合は
必ず親コンポーネント側で
変更する必要があるわけです
し逆にそうなっているので
非常にコードの流れが読みやすくて
保守性が高い安全なコードになるわけです
なのでbue.jsは意図的に
こんな風にデータの流れを制限しているんですね
ちょっとこちら消して
もう一度console.logのところも消しちゃいますね
他にもpropsは複数あっても大丈夫ですね
例えばこんな風にfubarとすると
ここでbarイコールbarとかとすると
ちゃんとbarを受け取ることができますので
適当にbarとすると
こんな風にですね
barを受け取ることができます
ちなみに今やったみたいに
vbindで指定しなかった場合は
普通の文字列として渡すのと同じ意味になります
なので例えばbarじゃなくて
Helloとかにした場合は
Helloという風に出ます
またこんな風に複数propsを指定する場合は
propsも属性ですので
ちょっと復習になるんですけれども
こんな風にvbindを書いて
そこにですね
who countbar helloみたいな風に
一気にオブジェクトで指定してもOKです
この場合も同じように動きますので
ちょっとリロードして
プラス1とかとすると
ちゃんとカウントアップされていると思いますし
Helloも出ているのが分かると思います
これはちょっと元に戻しておきたいと思います
また前回のセクションで
コンポーネントに属性を置いた場合は
そのコンポーネントの要素が
一つだけだったら
継承されるという話をしましたが
define propsで定義した属性に関しては
継承されないようになっています
なので例えばですけれども
Elementsタブで
このですね
countのpタグを見てみると
何もですね
継承されていないのが分かると思います
例えばbarとかを消すと
これbarは属性で指定しているんですけれども
その場合は
こんな風にbar helloと
ついてしまうのが分かると思います
だからdefine propsで定義されたものは
継承されないわけです
でもこれ
dara attributesに関しても同じで
こんな風に
dara attributesと書くと
本来であれば
指定された全ての属性を
オブジェクトのキーとバリューにするんですけれども
define propsで定義されたものは
含まずに
今回だったらbar helloだけを
含んだオブジェクトになります
なのでコンポーネントに
propsを定義したときに
それが
コンポーネントの要素にまで
継承されてしまうという
心配は一切ありませんので
ご安心ください
さあとpropsの
分割代入についても
説明したいんですけれども
ここのですね
返り値のところを
分割代入して書くことは
可能です
ここですね
分割代入ができる仕組みについても
軽く説明したいんですけれども
これですね
JavaScriptにおいて
分割代入をするということは
これどういう意味かというと
このコードと全く同じ意味を表すとすれば
whoという定数を定義して
その上でdefine propsの
whoプロパティにアクセスする
という意味ですね
これとこれは今全く同じ意味になるはずです
で
このdefine props.whoは
このdefine propsが
reactive object
このwhoはですね
親コンポーネントの方で
ref objectになっているんですけれども
reactive object内のref objectは
自動的に
ドットバリューが付きますよね
なので
このコードだけを考えると
この定数whoには
何が入るのかというと
これref objectが入るのではなく
reactive objectのref objectなので
バリューが付いて
結果的にただの
今だと0という数字が
このwhoに入ります
なので
今このwhoには
0という数字だけが入ると
考えられるわけですね
だからreactivity systemとかは
一切ないわけです
なので
例えばですけれども
watch effectとかを使って
このwhoの中身の変更を
検知したいという時に
例えばconsole.logで
whoとかとすると
これはただの0という数字ですので
変更検知できないのかなと思いますよね
これとこれは同じ意味で
これはただの0が入るだけなので
ただですね
view.jsは
実はこのwhoが
reactive systemを損なわないような仕組みを
内部で提供してくれているんですね
どうしてるかというと
このviewのファイルを
javascriptに変換する時に
この分割代入の部分を全て解析して
元々のpropsというデータに直した上で
全てのそのpropsのプロパティを使っている部分に
props.のような形で
分割代入前のコードに書き換えてくれるんですね
これだとちゃんとwatch effectは
reactive objectのref objectにアクセスしていると
こういう認識になって
ちゃんとですね
変更検知してくれるようになります
なのでこんな風に分割代入で書いた場合は
最終的にはこういう風に
また元に戻してくれていると
こういうことを理解しておいてください
なので今この状態でも
view.jsがいい感じにやってくれているので
ちゃんとですね
コンソールを見てみると
こんな風にですね
風の変更を検知してコンソールが実行されているのが
分かると思います
これですね
もし変換後のJavaScriptを見たい場合は
このですね
デベロッパーツールのネットワークタブで
ちょっとリロードして
少し小さくして
このshowcount.viewですね
今の場合
このコンポーネントを見れば
ここですね
watch effectのところを見れば分かるんですけれども
ちゃんと underscoreと付いていますが
風だけじゃなくて
props.fuと
こういう形に変換してくれているのが分かると思います
なので最終的にはですね
こういう分割材入をしていても
分割材入をしていない形に戻してくれると
こういう風になっているので
ちゃんとリアクティビティシステムを損なわずに
分割材入できると
こういう仕組みが成り立っています
一つ注意点として
もしですね
watchを使って
このfの変更を検知したい場合
これ第一域数にfを入れたら
最終的にはprops.fuのような形に変換されてしまいまして
結果的にですね
この第一引数には
ドットバリューが自動でついて
数字の0が入っているのと
同じ意味になってしまいますので
この時はですね
リアクティブオブジェクトの
プロパティのように扱う必要がありますので
こんな風に関数で指定するようにしてください
で
propsはいりませんね
こうすると
これでもですね
ちゃんと変更を検知してくれるようになりますので
例えばですけれども
ここでwatchと押して
console.logを
ちょっとこちらコンソールとして
見てみると
はいこんな風にですね
ちゃんとwatchが出ているのが分かると思います
もしこれですね
第一引数に直接
このpropsを入れてしまうと
こんな風にですね
エラーが出るようになっていますので
必ず関数で指定する必要があります
のでここですね
気をつけてください
はいでは次は
ちょっとこちらですね
ずっと警告が出ていると思うんですけれども
ここについてですね
次のレクチャーで説明したいと思います
お待ちしております